[Music]
coming up on fyi
political drama as the prime minister
steps down and the search begins to find
his replacement there should be a new
leader therefore a new prime minister
plus why the rising cost of food means
our school lunches are changing
and we meet some of the uk's youngest
filmmakers picking up awards and the
winner is
mia made by zoe from aberdeen
[Music]
hi there this is your weekly news show
where we investigate all the big stories
and you get your say we've got loads of
info to share with you as always
starting with school meals
so we've been hearing from you that some
of your favorite foods are missing from
school meals turkey instead of chicken
for example and beef and fish is off the
menu so we've been investigating and
it's all because of the rising costs of
food so the companies that are
responsible for looking after our school
meals that caterers have said that
they've had to reduce our options you
know and what we can have at lunch and
switch to more cheaper meats and process
food basically everything has gotten
more expensive hasn't it i mean like
clothes food electricity gas and petrol
drivers have been staging protests like
this you know driving really slowly on
the motorway to make a point about
petrol prices rising and how much
they've gone up and it's all because of
fossil fuels like gas and oil you know
they're needed for petrol and
electricity and because you know they're
in short supply it means that the price
of them has gone off it means that
making and delivering goods have become
more expensive as well and they pass
that cost onto the customer and what
they charge us and of course i think the
war has played its part as well because
we used to get a lot of stuff from
ukraine so the government provides the
money to the caterers that then provide
our school meals and the government
released a statement saying that they
are reviewing the rising costs and they
also point out that they are providing
more free school meals than ever before
to support families that are struggling
but it doesn't look like helping
families who are short of money or
ending the war in ukraine is going to be
at the top of the government agenda they
need to find a new prime minister it is
clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister yep more political drama as
boris johnson quit but why well a
growing number of politicians in his
party the conservatives demanded he
stepped down they weren't happy with his
performance and accused him of lying and
letting the public down but he insisted
on staying put so in protest a growing
number of politicians resigned from
their government roles until it got to
the point where he just had to resign
earlier this year boris johnson told fyi
he's aware some people want him out but
he just wants to get on with the job at
a difficult time for the country and
help ukraine my job is to is to continue
and the great thing about
democratic politics
is that we have a we have a system
whereby the people
can remove you
now the conservative party will have to
elect a replacement but the other
political parties are demanding a
general election so the public gets to
decide who runs the country
here's some more stories we've spotted
and it turns out one of them is fake
news
here is greta tunberg making a speech at
the glastonbury music festival
but loads of fans took to social media
complaining of double standards
arguing that while she urged people to
do more to save the planet the stage was
being powered by a diesel generator
which contributes to global warming fake
news or fact
and there have been claims that these
wax worms could be the key to getting
rid of plastic waste they love eating it
and it's good for them for a bit of fun
we'll give you the rest of the show to
figure out which story is fake
terrorism has been hitting the headlines
again it's the 17th anniversary of when
london was hit by one of the worst
terror attacks in the uk
explosions were set off on the london
underground and on a bus in 2005. and
you may have heard about the biggest
trial ever of terrorists in france 20
men have been found guilty of being
behind the country's worst ever
terrorist attack in paris in 2015. now
we're told that terrorism is still
really rare but why does it happen and
what can we do to protect ourselves
tilly has been investigating
[Music]
terrorism has been a threat to the way
that we live our lives for a very long
time
to put it very simply terrorism is when
a group of people or an individual use
extreme violence to try and frighten us
into changing the way we think or behave
so how long has terrorism been going on
for
well remember remember the 5th of
november gunpowder treason and plot
you've probably heard that nursery rhyme
before right
but did you know it's actually about one
of the earliest examples of terrorism
here in the uk
the so-called gunpowder plot happened
back in 1605 when a man called guy
fawkes tried to blow up the houses of
parliament
but before fox could light the fuse he
was caught
the event is still remembered with
fireworks every november 5th
so what about these days how likely are
we to become a victim of terrorism
well it's completely understandable that
some of us do worry about this but what
i found out is that terrorist attacks in
the uk are extremely rare
in fact if you look at the statistics
you're more likely to be killed by a
lightning strike than by a terrorist
most terrorist attacks happen in
countries with a recent history of
conflict or political unrest
like afghanistan iraq and nigeria
but the most deadly attack of this
century happened in the usa
four passenger jets were hijacked by a
terrorist group called al-qaeda two of
the planes were flown deliberately into
new york's tallest skyscrapers killing
nearly 3 000 people
the third plane crashed into the united
states military headquarters the
pentagon
and the fourth plane crashed into a
field after a struggle between
passengers and the terrorists
[Music]
the attack has become known as 911
because it happened on the 11th day of
the 9th month september
it was carried out by terrorists from
the middle east who wanted to enforce an
extreme version of the islamic religion
on the muslim world islam is a peaceful
religion but this small network of
people adopted violence and brutal laws
to enforce their extreme beliefs
their plan was to overthrow any
government in the muslim world that
stood in their way and terrorized
western countries that supported those
governments they also said they wanted
to punish western countries for
attacking their countries throughout
history so even though terrorist attacks
are very rare what do experts advise the
public to do if they're ever faced with
an incident
well the police say there are three
simple words which could save lives
run hide and tell the first thing to do
is to run away and try to find somewhere
safe to hide
making sure mobile phones are turned to
silent so the attackers aren't alerted
to where people are hiding
then finally once it's safe the advice
is to tell the police about what's
happened by ringing the emergency number
999
[Music]
and remember if you're still worried
about terrorism then it's a good idea to
speak to an adult who you trust they
should be able to help and reassure you
for more explainers head to our webpage
you'll find loads of videos helping you
out if you don't get why things happen
or complicated issues from racism and
wars to climate change and fake news
we've been investigating
[Music]
here's a viral video that's a bit of a
heart stopper
this highly trained daredevil walked
from one mountain peak to another in
austria using a slack rope a very thin
line of webbed fibers
[Music]
well this is my favorite omg video a
photographer got this amazing footage of
a great white razor sharp teeth it's
images like this that give sharks a bad
rap i mean they are terrifying but
attacks on humans are still really
really rare
we all love shooting videos and sharing
them with our friends but have you ever
thought that you might be good enough to
become a professional filmmaker yes so i
headed to an award ceremony to meet the
winners of a filmmaking competition some
of those films were absolutely amazing
yeah they were and this wasn't just any
award ceremony
yes so another glamorous red carpet
event has rolled out guys i mean there
are celebrities everywhere but this time
they're only giving out awards because
the into film ceremony is all about
young filmmakers
the insta film award celebrates the best
the uk has to offer in filmmaking by us
young people
the nominated films cover topics like
the impact of lockdown in mental health
the struggle to protect the environment
climate change ukrainian cultural
identity and a film about ocd
driven to despair
so basically it was about a girl with
ocd who takes the bus and then misses
her stop and it's how she has to kind of
deal with the fallout of that and deal
with like the rising anxiety and i think
it does end on like quite a positive
note we got a drum roll please
the year the world changed by pupils
from bessica primary school in doncaster
you tell us a little bit about what your
movie was all about so it was about the
first lockdown and how it affected
everybody differently i don't think i
could have made a film as good as your
guys now let alone when i was 11 or
under it's just incredible
the 2022 changes for a better world
award goes to
change direction
i want you to panic
i want you to feel the fear i feel every
day
i am passionate about fighting climate
change and love making films which help
spread the message
it's food fight
[Music]
our film is about food fight and we
thought of all the different puns to say
watch out and we just had the best time
making it another one bites the crust
good like six months of at least
planning it we've got we got a lot of it
filmed and then covered happened and the
winner is
mia made by zoe from aberdeen
so my movie's about someone's loved one
passing away and basically them bit
struggling with it and the main message
is that you're not alone there's other
people that are going through it as well
and if you talk to them it will help a
lot and
yeah you're not alone in the journey you
can reach so many people by the medium
film it's a huge kind of
tool that we can use to make the world a
better place and i strongly believe that
especially with people like this you
know it's just such a great way of young
people being able to express their mind
and really portray their voice in the
most
brilliant of ways and and there's so
many ways to do it and the way that
these young people have done it has been
really inspiring for me as a creative
well what a day it's been i've met some
incredible young filmmakers looking to
break through in this industry and boy
are they doing a good job
[Music]
nice one and well done to all of you but
it did get us thinking though are there
enough opportunities for people of all
different backgrounds in the film and tv
business especially on screen
we are seeing more diversity for example
take the new cast of doctor who but is
enough being done that's the question we
put to an fy news club at st michael's
school
[Music]
yes
after doctor who the tv franchise mixed
first step of giving um a black actor a
chance of being the main role and also a
transgender person as a companion um i
think that many more movies and many
more tv shows are going to start doing
this as well i think this is going to
mean that we're going to see a lot more
black actors and a lot more like gay and
trans and members of the lgbtq in those
kind of tv shows it's the 21st century
gotta be diverse it's also women like
you know the last doctor who before this
one right yeah there was um a female
actor yeah that was the first time in
like
yeah in
a long time there wasn't even any female
main characters was there before it was
white male leads and it's really good
how they're inviting other people like
of other ethnicities and sexualities to
do different things now because it just
makes it more inclusive and maybe more
people will watch it make it even better
ah i'm excited about the new
companions oh yeah
ah i love
yes
she's such like um a staple figure
yeah in like the british queer community
when you look at the tv you might think
oh you don't really see yourself but
when they're showing like diversity and
like same-sex relationships or people of
color you can definitely sort of look at
the tv like as a role model i mean just
for the fact that um doctor who is
adding black people as their main
character and um
transgender people as they can find him
just that for that fact i might even
watch it today i might even go to my tv
today and watch it today i mean we
filmed it oh okay not okay when it comes
out when it comes out yeah yeah i was
just testing
remember if you want to have your say on
an issue right here on fyi just head to
our webpage at first dot news slash fyi
you'll get all the info on how to set up
an fyi news club at your school
ok let's reveal the fake news we spotted
rumors the stage greta tunberg made a
speech on was powered by a diesel
generator were fake organizers of the
glastonbury music festival reacted
saying the generator used
environmentally friendly biofuel
so the revelation that these wax worms
eat plastic is facts they get their name
because they love honey but the makeup
of honey is similar to plastic so
according to scientists they're able to
digest it we'll need a lot of these
worms to clear up the world's plastic
waste though
remember if you want more help in
spotting fake news then just head to our
webpage at first dot news forward slash
fyi where you can find loads of tips and
explainers well that's about it from fyi
but before we go corbin wanted to share
a big moment in his life with us we'll
leave you with his snaps that went viral
of him wearing a red dress to his school
from it's allowed cheers from pupils and
staff at the archbishop sancroft high
school corbyn says it sends a message
you can be who you want to be and his
mum is really proud of him see you next
time
[Music]